pas pour demain olivier lui débutera
après demain après sa jeune consoeur
dimanche n'est ce pas sur l'antenne pour
présenter les programmes de la soirée
c'est la soirée voilà alors olivier lui
aussi aime beaucoup la télé mais c'est
un passionné de théâtre comme vous allez
le constater sur ces images
notre reportage c'est juliette c'est le
soleil de minuit
madame
parle parle encore
o'neill tempèrent leurs plus ton nom et
en échange pour moi toute entière je te
prends mon nom mois seulement amour ce
sera comme un autre baptême jeu mais
plus je ne serai et roméo qui es tu
quittes rabie chaki sont des pensées
secrètes marocain non je ne saurais te
dire qui je suis puisque je hais le mien
on belle jeune fille d'être ton ennemi
commun timonier 10 sur les ailes légère
de l'amour j'ai volé par dessus les murs
aucun mur de pierres ne peux t'empêcher
l'amour de voler c'est pourquoi je ne
craque pas ta famille je me battrai et
ça lui arrive souvent olivier minne de
jouer les roméo comme ça dans paris
notre image et des jeunes filles son nom
rarement j'ai rarement conter fleurette
comme ça depuis une rue alors olivier
sera sur le sens nantes à dimanche comme
le laisse supposer la couleur de ses
yeux de ses cheveux ce garçon est
d'origine belge
en plus ce n'est pas une blague belge
tout à fait tout à fait bon comment il
en est venu à la télévision olivier pour
finir et bien une passion depuis autres
qui m'est venue depuis très longtemps et
puis voilà quand on a envie on fait tout
pour
bon ils seront sur le minitel très
prochainement olivier gerolami il traîne
un bouquet voilà alors je leur souhaite
personnellement parce que c'est un
métier que je connais bien
autant de plaisir que j'ai eu à le
pratiquer et puis beaucoup de réussite
antenne 2 et je suis sûr vous les
accueillerez à bras ouverts demain c'est
floriane et dimanche olivier l'autre
olivier gerolami responsable et mitel
merci d'être venus également ce matin de
faire connaître le service minitel
je vous souhaite une bonne journée une
bonne matinée à la prochaine fois pour
tout savoir sur les coulisses d'antenne
de revoir merci